[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to a
uh better late than never edition of
honest trailer commentaries sorry a
little technical difficulties this
morning oh and it looks like danielle
she's back no i just like my my camera
keeps having schmutz on it i don't know
if it's the fires or what's happening uh
we all know the dangers of a schmutzy
camera classic schmutz camera yeah
um we today will be talking about our
deepest darkest thoughts about the squid
game and all of its contestants and
revelations uh we'll be going through
the honest trailer with you and showing
you some deleted scenes uh we also have
some clips from not clips we have a
tease for next week's honest trailer and
we'll be responding to viewer comments
and questions uh it's gonna be a good
one and look i've seen the comments yeah
we goofed we messed up we forgot to
mention ali one of the four uh probably
like core members of this not take full
responsibility for that that was a cut
that i made at the last minute but this
is what happens when you bust your ass
to rush to turn around a squid game on
his trailer like a week after the show
got popular and anyone was even talking
about it mistakes will be made do you
want it on time do you want it fast or
do you want it good those are your
choices people i uh i had also written i
thought a pretty decent little joke
about the very religious guy who doesn't
even get a name he's like player 200 240
something
nobody got upset that he was left out i
guess because it was so annoying and ali
is likeable
about ali is he's if let's all figure
out what our take whatever should have
been because to me i found him likable
and sweet and what he did what seemed
like more of an accident than anything
and that's there's just not much funny
about it
no there's nothing funny about ali it's
all like he's sweet like a very sweet
person who's very tragic yeah i don't
know i want to ring a joke out of it but
mostly my joke is like it's a joke that
he had to be in the squid games like
like it sucks like it's
people take advantage of immigrants
you you really think i i did try to
write subject nothing i thought was like
worth putting in but uh
i there is
very early on they set up he's got like
super strength like he's able to like
hold up the main guy with just like one
arm and it's you know it's taxing for
him but he's able to do it and then that
does not get paid off you think that
later there's going to be a some sort of
feat of strength they're going to need
him for
never never really pays off to have him
on the team
yeah
his gullibility was really the that's
why you want him on the team is like at
the crucial moment you will be able to
fool him pull one over on this guy yeah
you will be able to switch out the rocks
for marbles and uh that's how you'll get
them but only if you're an smu grad
because that's the kind of that's the
caliber
yeah so for business like that's the
only way that anyone in this movie is in
this series is smart i looked it up i
was like because they kept mentioning
like that neighborhood from seoul that
they're from and and it's like it's a
large area like more than one person
from that neighborhood got into college
for sure for sure this is one of those
things i saw comments where everyone was
like well that's like the most
prestigious university and it's like hey
yeah if someone was going around talking
about how someone went to harvard to us
all day long we would also make fun of
them yeah we would still be like well
come on i mean i went to oh you went to
oxford oh you went to oxford like we
would also make fun of it but it would
be like if you were from
like if you were from boston and you
were like you know he got into harvard
it's like it's down the street i'm not
that impressed
yeah suck at smu uh or harvard i don't
know who we're mad at
i think we're we're mad at harvard
yeah we're always mad at harvard smu
business from their business school very
impressed but yeah this is i think that
there was obviously a um a fire under us
to do this and props to lon who just
like was like oh not only have i watched
this but here are here's like eight
pages of well formatted thoughts
yeah um but this is i think we are
always in a rush to do netflix flash in
the pan stuff because frankly like
that's these have two weeks of relevance
and then everybody stops talking about
whatever this week's netflix show was so
i don't want to say we cut corners but
we did go fast so let's now take our
time put your feet up ease in oh we're
not sonicking this anymore
pop open pressure we're no longer a blue
hedgehog
don't have to go fast let's just uh
cruise through the honest trailer for
squid game hit it
the following trailer is for spoilers
water
best flavored seltzer yeah
[Music]
welcome to korean netflix home of zombie
killers and elaborate headgear and 500
000 shows about shy teens in love but
now gets the intense global sensation
that's making americans whose only
exposure to battle royale concepts is
fortnite and whose only exposure to
korean film is parasite say
i'm getting serious parasite meets four
night vibes from this
squid game
yeah uh plus
i feel like i'm such just like uh i'm
such a sucker for a show like this or
this show because i love battle royale
concepts and i love uh like
class-based horror film concepts um this
is just like it's this is just peanut
butter and jelly for me um i would i
think i was gonna like this uh from the
time i found out what it was uh did this
immediately when you guys over or or
does it take some time for you
oh i mean they like uh uh aside from
obviously like the
the the slapping and the gambling and
the no one once they got to the slapping
i want to get the slapping you were in
i don't know what that says about me
um because like the gambling and all
that stuff obviously it was really
interesting and all the stuff with like
him and his daughter like all of that
stuff was incredibly compelling um but i
i will confess i did not know i could
turn off the dubbing into the second
episode so the first episode i'm like
okay and the second episode i turned off
the dubbing went to the subbing and then
went not to english closed caption
subbing but the english sub and was like
this is supreme that's how i watched it
after thankfully i waited long enough
that the articles came out of like this
is the right way to watch squid games so
uh i i think that might have improved it
for me because i was in from
the sl even even pre-slap just like a
scumbag main character like oh this guy
sucks oh that's fun you just don't see
that as much as you should ever uh these
days
he's like 40 and he sucks normally you
see it's like oh he's like 25 and he
sucks he has some time but if you're 40
and you suck you just suck forever yeah
there's a that's not true you still have
time okay
you still have
time
second best time is now
don't don't catch yourself but this is
now a self this is now a self
improvement uh life tomorrow never comes
uh
there's a japanese show called allison
borderland you guys remember that there
was also on netflix it has a similar
setup where it's like uh in that one
it's like all of a sudden like all the
power goes out in tokyo and then when it
comes back like most people are just
gone there's like still people left but
only a few compared to what it used to
be they're all kind of alone in this
emptied out city and then again there
are these like life or death games and
challenges they have to play now that
one is like sci-fi like some alien or
robot or like crazy supernatural
intelligence is doing this to them and
so when squid game first came along i
was like oh this would be interesting to
like compare and contrast and um so i
was kind of interested in just hearing
about it at first it did take me a few
weeks until it was like a worldwide
phenomenon to like finally dig in just
because there's like you know you got a
queue but uh yeah i was interested right
off the bat just because i like survival
thriller i guess they're calling this
genre
i just like these kinds of premises
since battle royale era you know and i
definitely kept my mind open um for
sci-fi shenanigans but i was also like
the world's most dangerous game is man
as i think i've said it many times
there's that that first moment where you
see the like m.c escher room that they
all have to walk through and i was like
oh is this going to be the reveal that
it's like fantasy or sound like they're
in like there's gonna like the gravity's
gonna turn off like i thought for a
moment i was bracing myself for like
it's magic or they're in space or it's
dark scenes fun production design and
then uh yeah yeah it's also like so much
darker that like the people who designed
this was like
you know who i like
and you know what i like if i'm gonna
watch people walk i'm going to watch
them walk interestingly like the idea
that like that was the idea but behind
the people who designed this room like
yeah because they brought in architects
yeah i don't know if they knew what they
were doing
there's a whole lot of questions about
is this like practical like it's not a
realistic world but i was still like
palpably relieved that it wasn't like
aliens or it's like some actual squid
science experiment or something that
it's like no no it's just like
messed up yeah no this is like a
backdoor pilot for virtuosity
right yeah like i was like i hope
they're not something like that like
they're not it's not tron or whatever
but like no no it's just their computer
i was waiting for jamiroquai to just
like virtual insanity and just do like
the backwards moonwalk that's the final
game
we're all given like huge fuzzy top hats
all right let's keep playing solo's
hottest extreme competition is squid
game this show has everything dramatic
life or death stakes playstation
controller cosplay human furniture old
men soiling themselves organ harvesting
and you can do a human marble which is a
thing where you play marvel's with your
best friend until one of you loses the
will to compete
these positives just briefly we we try
to uh as stefan and not as stefan and
stefan's probably gonna win every time
sorry i like that you could just write
we could just write things and i don't
know if john has a stephon but i'm like
dad daddy
this is not his first stephon though
because he's done this before in a
couple other trips like mostly for
starrings for people and stuff like that
oh right maybe we've had it it made a
jump to the to the main body of the trip
so uh
we're gonna ring as much as we can out
of that until
uh we have i mean sometimes you think
it's stefan runs those are really funny
you know it's a good format
uh all right keep going first we'll face
off in a series of children's games for
a shot at 45 billion korean wan which
works out to let's see here i'm gonna
carry the one divided by rotation earth
um about three lindsay lohan fury nfts
but for the losers there's a different
kind of prize piping hot lead
[Applause]
the point is they
in this colorful height of social
commentary and thriller that involves
sorry boss and they do and and and just
to say like they do die in other ways
it's just like that was mostly they get
shot
yeah they or fall
i need to go back were those squibs in
the squid game or was that digi did you
blood splatter
i i think that is some of a little bit
of both i think it's like digi and then
i think that like if it's like an
up-close shot like i think that those
are squibs i was gonna say the same
thing there are definitely some times
where they'll show a guy like get like
get like a bunch of shots like close up
and those are squibs you could see like
the little bits flying off or whatever
uh to give it that kind of 80s almost
like verhoveny feel something i'll take
it yeah i am a man
a dying of thirst in the desert here
just looking for one squib
but yeah like the looks like the red
light green light scene where a bunch of
people are getting shot all over the
place from a distance that's all that's
all digital
reference that i don't know if i want to
make now well you think about that well
let's just say if the art of squibbery
can make even a partial comeback i think
we'll all be better for it as a society
because the it's just not the same when
you have the little cgi spray it never
looks good how hard is it to rig i guess
because they have to change clothes
between takes like why do they not do
this i feel like stuff like the john
wick scenes may not even be possible
like the timing of those long takes with
all those squibs i don't know like i get
it on that level when it's like john
wick is going to shoot 40 people in the
head
going
there's just something visceral about
when a pack explodes on you and then you
see someone like go backwards like on
that arm and like we know they're all
very talented actors obviously they
could do it without it but there is just
something miserable about when something
explodes on you yeah no i mean it's like
robocop is robocop in part because it
looks like people are really being like
blown apart you know yeah you said every
everything fairhope like total recall i
mean yeah it turns people into
campbell's chunky soup right i mean like
those movies are like peak squid
like this
i'm still gonna do my i'm still gonna do
my bear hove and uh uh watch along
someday we're doing it let's do it i'm
in all right let's keep going commentary
and thriller that invites you to pass
judgment on the creepy dudes and masks
watching all of this go down for their
own entertainment i mean what kind of
sick society would even ask people to
hurt themselves for your entertainment i
mean right ugh gross even think about it
never mind it's pretty funny
excuse forever next time you're a fanfic
that dares to ask what if the weird
middle-aged people who exclusively read
dystopian y-a have to experience their
horrors firsthand
middle-aged people who exclusively read
why that's a that's a genre of person
right that exists
do you i mean you don't believe me i've
i've just remained blissfully unaware of
of why a discourse online and
about romantic y.a and like the people
that religiously follow that
there are definitely people my age who
just read like why
books like for sure and listen i'm not
judging them except that i think they're
like the people in squid game who are my
age and forced to play the squid game
that's all that's the only comparison
got it got it i don't judge if you want
to just read maze runner like great more
power to you that's fine i don't know
it's like you're reading you're both
honestly like
90 of people who are not even doing that
it's just shorter than reading a dance
book that's the only difference like
they're all the same direct it's just
shorter right well right because it's
not like the people who if you most
adults if you're not reading the base
runner like what are you you're already
pinch on you're reading you know like
john grisham it's not like dan brown
it's all like degrees you know
yeah
yeah where my uh where's my grisham
heads at welcome back to book talk
[Laughter]
hey y'all asked us to name a book and we
couldn't before and now we named several
so do not talk to us about naming books
again
this has been naming books
with the three of us that's proving that
we know what books are yeah
we did it i read peas for potty twice
yesterday um
for my kid all right keep going
firsthand and meet gee hun a stand-in
for every male tv rider and that he's a
good guy at heart but a bad dad he'll
get one chance at redemption if he can
win the squid game unfortunately he's
bad at killing however he is elite at
standing next to people getting killed
but he's not alone fighting alongside
gihon is his childhood friend song woo
apparently the only guy from seoul who
got into
he was like a evil banker right what
scale was his fraud on i forget was he
just defining like individuals or was he
a big big baller i think it was a pretty
big baller i don't think that he was
like on a scale of um he wasn't doing
like massive massive fraud but he was
definitely i don't know
they didn't say if he was doing like
those huge schemes that like defraud old
ladies and stuff it sounded like he was
just defrauding like the company which
um yes i mean i just wonder how i
thought it was like embezzlement like
that i didn't think it was like he was
running it's not a ponzi scheme yeah
right no he was like stealing from his
company i wonder how i just wonder how
which i'm like four basically like go
for it man
how do you have to be to know about
squid game is it really just
uh bezos or is it like because a lot of
people have to know about squid game it
takes a lot to put this show together it
is a lot of effort it's very much a wag
the dog thing where i'm like what are
they
how many people are involved and how
many of you are straight up murdered and
dumped into the pacific ocean like after
yeah well i i also feel like i think
because i'm i'm just gonna say i'm sure
the cop is coming back like we don't see
his dead body so the implication to me
is cop comes back
me yeah that probably is what we will
get into in season two is like they must
the government and the authorities must
know about the squad you can't hide an
island like i mean the guy the spoiler
alert i guess it's like the guy was a
a bank executive the old man that was
secretly running all of it i mean yeah
but like people know what he looks like
he's a very high level like he's a
billionaire level guy i think could you
name could you describe a coke for me
right now
can i describe what a cup brother
describe for me a coke one's dead um
describe what they look like okay you
have no idea no no
i can reverse engineer that from there
from their kids
one of them he's tall he's got he's very
like jowly he's got that old white guy
jowly thing and he's got wiring glasses
he looks like an old white guy in glass
he looks you know what he's got like a
jeb bush vibe like he's like an older
i would say maybe even a little bit
paunchier jeb bush i just i don't think
like if look
i understand what elon musk looks like i
could not explain him to a room of
people elon musk looks like oh sorry uh
spencer's mic just went out but that's
fine because now i'm just gonna do this
thing right now we're just gonna
describe you now they're just gonna call
me a communist um so uh elon musk to me
looks like if you made tom cruise in ms
paint like that's the only way i could
describe elon musk
sure yeah i i could see that though so
so so i'm like trying to think of how
you would describe that dude to people
and you would just be like yeah man he's
like
old he has like gray hair oh what was
was the suggestion like people should
recognize him or something like i didn't
think that would oh yeah yeah yeah i
think that the suggestion was like no
one would know who this dude is and i'm
like no i don't i don't i don't know if
anybody would know who that dude was in
the squid game i just here's the thing i
didn't like about are we just assuming
everybody knows the end of squid game
here is this oh we have to because it's
already a spoiler alert like if you're
watching this you can just charge
through yeah any honest trailer
commentaries is spoiler
because so that guy is competing in the
tug of war
and if his team were to lose their the
guards would have no way to intervene he
would just die with the rest of his team
so he's already dying yeah we have to
assume he was willing to die in the
squid game if that's what how it worked
out
but then after the marbles game why
don't they really shoot him
shouldn't he have died
so i took the marbles game as a metaphor
for hahaha this old dude is losing his
marbles
does that sound right
like that's that hello
i was just getting into how the marble
game was like a metaphor for how the old
dude was losing his right but let me set
this up for spencer so my question was
and i think i posed this in slack before
because this would bother me
the old man had was participating in the
tug of war
if his team had lost the guards wouldn't
be able to save him he would have just
died with his team so i that made me
assume
he is willing to die in the squid game
if that's how it came down he wants to
play and playing means dying if you lose
but then when he's playing marbles he
loses
but then he doesn't die he they save him
and he dies in bed why doesn't he die
after the marbles game if you're rich
you get to choose the rules whenever you
want that's how i had like a little
little guard
no i don't want to like i'm done i'm
done
i think that was another layer of
commentary along this that that rules
didn't apply to him
but then wouldn't he have had some sort
of way out of the tunnel no i think he
would have died in tug of war like
that's what i think
i honestly think that he was waiting for
that moment when he got his rocks off he
hadn't gotten them yet and when he told
second sorry when he told
when he told jihan that he was basically
like oh you thought it was cool to like
cheat this old man though and got to see
him like die in his eyes in front of him
he was like i'm cool
i don't need to die
i post this to a few people that's my
favorite read on it so far is that it
was he was waiting for it to be like
satisfying and then once it was
satisfying it was like all right i'm
good yeah i think it was super
satisfying for him to be like you tried
to cheat me i'm an old man you're as
terrible as i am okay bye but then
what's up with the like it's got to be a
perfect meritocracy pure fair to like
who is that is that the front man
i have to i have to interrupt with some
new information helpfully from the chat
um uh i don't know how to pronounce this
name still jen van rilgensbergen uh says
objection his chains did not have locks
on them and langley emily writes i've
not seen it but i hear he wasn't locked
to the rope like everyone i didn't
notice that
that's the first time
i've i've posted this at least at least
10 10 12 people this is the first actual
answer
well well done well done this is what
the easter egg articles are for this is
the one time those have ever been just
i mean i like i like trying to puzzle it
out but that's very good so he did if
they he would have just been like
oh all right everybody you've been great
oh no they forgot to lock my fangs and
i'm so wildy and old
[Laughter]
i'm out slowly climbs down the tower
while everybody just grim it just gets
pissed i mean what are they like the
guards have guns there's nothing they
could they could do he'd just be like mr
burns
driving away in the car while everybody
throws pretzels
he's been specific by a barrage of
pretzels very specific simpsons raphael
yeah all right keep playing
this grandpa who makes it really far
into the competition because he's the
only one old enough to have played games
outside as a kid
a thug who leads the squid game's
toughest squid gang which isn't saying
much they don't so much jump you in as
let you stand next to them while you eat
a sad hard-boiled egg
is it weird that i think he's a
comfortable reminder to westerners that
north korea is a real place with actual
people
the wild card who's basically nick cage
reincarnated as a korean lady and some
random dudes who made it into the final
16 we can only assume that all their
horrible but tragically justified at
some point off camera
but while this crew squares off
there's a whole group of uh
of hufflepuffs you know
yeah
snuck by they must have been in their
own kind of uh neutral gang um but
that's fine i guess we won't see them in
the sequel but uh
we can all we can do the fanfic to fill
in the blanks there yeah i'm very
curious about you know like they're
they're obviously like the door is open
for whenever
not the stakes different stakes but same
games exactly are you gonna get her like
a honeycomb and see if she can i still
don't know what squid game is i thought
it was hopscotch but it's not hopscotch
oh my god the curls bye
bye
see ya well she's yeah i still do not
understand the rules of squid game they
tried uh
and they did a good job um kind of
translating it with like red light green
light like i know what that's all about
but there's no equivalent of squid game
except yeah like we don't have the
honeycomb game here but i was
immediately able to be like
yeah yeah okay i get what the game is i
just still don't like you're trying to
hit the circle but they're trying to
push you but then you have to hop on one
leg and it doesn't even really look like
a squid i was expecting them to do a
version of dodgeball with guns
that sounds cool i was waiting for dodgy
ball of gums yeah that's just shooting
because it's like just like a firing
squad or like shooting bullets like the
bullets of the balls or are you tossing
guns because that would be funnier just
i think like you're tossing guns oh yeah
i think you're throwing the gun and just
getting hit by it
and then you get to toss guns back then
whoever has the last gun gets to shoot a
bunch of people thanks there's a lot of
there's a squid game going on just off
camera
it's an afternoon stream that's on us
all right let's keep playing the trailer
where's it in ultimate stakes foursquare
take a peek behind the scenes of the
most brutal show to work for since ellen
from the among us crewmates who do all
the dirty work to the financial backers
who i'm pretty sure tommy lee jones from
jfk such a beautiful number
nice together
i suppose
i love
how
much they sound like dudes from comic
view doing white voices it's like the
thing that makes me
the happiest about that because it is
it's literally like people doing the
whitest voices it's like clearly voice
actors and like people who know what
they're doing
um
and it just it
it feels imperialist you know what i
mean like it just it feels like they own
a bunch of people
yeah no that that rang very true it
seemed like uh
those guys
who i guess were just like
caucasian actors in korea who were like
around and could hold a cigar
like you're you're hired um i mean yeah
i think they nailed every single one uh
great just the perfect
how many of them are the rumble
i it would have been the greatest
crossover in history to just have one of
them taking a money plane oh that is
just amazing it's just kelsey with the
cigar well that's i do think now that we
know this is a huge hit if they do come
back for squid game two a perfect
opportunity to cameo out those vip rolls
i was saying uh charlie day danny devito
rob mcelhaney and uh caitlin olsen
should be the floor next time the one
where they do a squid game yeah the one
the one where they do get the game does
a squid game
yeah
do you ever want to see a man do a squid
game yeah
squid game yeah i do because it is kind
of the setup of money playing like that
is all there is
but it actually pays off
right
the money play version doesn't make
sense this version was actually thought
out a little bit
somebody just recut the scenes from
money plane where they're making them
watch footage of like a person gets
stung by a bee or whatever but make it
quicker
they gamble on themselves playing
russian roulette it's like lawrence
brothers lawrence brothers no no
there are other movies about that you
gamble and other people play russian
related that way you live either way you
just lose money it's great
thank you from the old man in squid game
you always want to have an out in case
it's real yeah your turn
we should have known his number was
number one
all right what a giveaway yeah pictures
go-to indictment of capitalism killing
the poor's for sport or making them turn
on each other for a big prize oh if i
forgot about rat race i would kill my
best friend just a nazi smash mouth live
great finale so strap in for the violent
chaotic but also quietly heartbreaking
global sensation that blessed us with
some of 2021's easiest group halloween
costumes proves there's still an
audience for original content if it's
you know good and a truly depressing
number of people relate to being so
broke that you'd beat your childhood
bestie to death but no raising the
minimum wage if jack-in-the-box tacos
cost more than a dollar that's socialism
brother
starring
i'm from seoul but i'm not a soldier
oh that's chosen woo you went to college
at smu for business smart guy
a literal old boy
assistant to the regional manager
sadness everdeen
never squid with crazy
and sensitive thugs y'all need hugs
the bummer olympics
[Music]
all right there was that whole subplot
about the cop who was infiltrating the
squid game should we go back and like
figure out something to say about him to
tie all this in or
nah
yeah the cop thing i mean i look as a
the person who thinks about writing it's
like that's a that's clearly he's just
there to be your portal into revealing
different sizes
right we gotta see behind the scenes at
the squid game we can't just follow the
front man out of nowhere right i feel
like after the first like time you walk
into the pastel m.c escher murder room
you could be like okay i know this is
not good i'm going to try to get out of
here maybe i didn't necessarily need to
i mean i don't necessarily need to know
that they all sleep weird yeah it's like
i'm going to see how deep this rabbit
hole goes i'm going to just kind of
chill for a while it's mostly just like
they sleep weird and then they cook
together it's like everything you would
expect it's just them at work like
there's nothing that we learn about them
that isn't like oh like you're just well
because
he's there to eave drop on like the
game master and and you know whoever's
pulling the strings so right you need
somebody there but they could just cut
to that i don't know i also i ended up
feeling like the whole organ harvesting
thing he was investigating like it all
kind of doesn't really go anywhere like
it does feel like by the time you get to
the end like i don't really know if we
needed any of that like you could have
kind of just hinted at what it's like
behind the scenes and then we see the
vips when they show up and like i don't
really think you needed this whole
files in the back of the room and oh
it's my brother and like none of it goes
anywhere and i i don't know i guess it's
nice to know that none of the human is
wasted you know like if you hunt a human
it gotta use every part that's true
that's nice
it's it's like it's like gore which i'm
full like i'm for it you know like
that's your four-door i'm always good
with just like
i think that stuff all taken together is
probably one episode one full episode
you could cut from the series and that's
a netflix tradition as being at least
one episode two yeah
they spread it over so it's like you're
only bored for three minutes every show
and i mean now that they're assured to
get another season if they want it there
probably is more stuff to do there now
that we know that there's that
connection and whatever
and we still got to figure out
jihan's
kool-aid hair or whatever yeah that's
true he's got it he's got a new look so
i you know it very much reminds me of
when you go to college and you're away
from a small town you're a girl and
you're just like i'm going to buzz all
my hair off he's like i'm just going to
dye it red i'm going to become the joker
oh yeah
all right this is uh we cut stuff um
believe it or not so let's see what we
didn't see the original starrings i
don't think did we finish those oh we
didn't finish the last one did we finish
that we got it
i'm sorry i interrupted and i never say
pause and so it's always weird when i do
it
it's all good um yeah i think we have uh
um
yeah exactly we're all out of sorts
because this is this is our morning show
not ours yeah
from the country that brought you squid
monsters and squid eaters comes the
latest chapter in korea's fictional
squidovers
squid game
this dying old man who somehow makes it
really far into the competition
basically squid game sanjaya this
extremely irritating religious man who
along with midnight mass is making it
pretty clear where netflix stands on the
whole catholicism thing
they're 100 fully committed to the exact
same platform as the 2021 republican
party
being gay
and it's totally okay if you die
starring ow dad jokes goofus and gallon
the smart of killing won't you bleed my
neighbor old bay
it is a tuma the mask storm shadow so
cobra was behind this all along
girl from the north country
call me snake
brutes and ladders manic pixie night
terror
and alia booboo
and i pakistan him
on deadly playground
squid pro quo
nursery crimes
well there you go you got your you got
your alley uh mentioned in the deleted
scenes uh i just found out a little too
late that uh the first part of the
pakistan thing is a ethnic slur so i
just got that
and then the uh
booboo
we could we could if you want it
take it but sorry for all those people
yeah for the people who uh miss ali
please uh mad libs your own starring
into it for us please i was trying to
come up with a prince ali like a little
rhyme and make john saying the prince
ali song but then i was like i think i
did that before and that's when you know
yeah walk back from the edge of the
cliff
written the same aladdin parody song
multiple times
well this brings us into our uh our
questions from chat and um i think that
this one will have an interesting answer
from reality check do you prefer asking
do you prefer having time to breathe and
ruminate on a non-trailer for a film
with a theatrical release or do you like
the immediacy of these quick turnaround
streaming trailers and i think that it
is obviously a give and take and uh i
like the immediacy because not
everybody's already made these same
jokes hopefully uh but the uh but you
don't have you just don't have as much
time to absorb it especially when it's a
series not a not a movie you know i'm
watching as i'm giving notes and stuff
like that that's that's not ideal but i
think that's the reality of netflix and
mirrors the netflix development process
which is like screw it let's just make
stuff and throw it up there
as fast as you can we just need more
content for the content hole yeah um and
sometimes you get a squid game and and
most times you don't uh but that's tiger
king being the other big one last year i
think tiger king was a top top three on
his trailer for us for the year that was
yeah
um
brent dreyer writes uh danielle would
win the screen junkie squid game i don't
know
yeah i'm not i don't think i'd be very
good at killing no or allowing people to
be killed right yeah
i'm sure i would be one of those people
like the red light green light where
it's just starting and they're like wait
what's going on like
like that would be me or i'd be like out
immediately
dead and so it would be between
everybody else that would be my luck
because i'd be one of the people in the
back doing red light green light and
then when everyone was realizing you
were getting super shot up everyone
would just like trample over my body
yeah ryan i would i would put money on
uh
ryan i think ryan could probably uh he
you know he could probably slip by for
sure yeah
he got got youth and like you know like
dexterity on a back good idea
wow these are the future i'm not gonna
do great
can we put this on my yearly review this
is awesome
we probably will
survive
i'm telling billy uh yeah billy would do
well too um
so oh billy would
murder it i shouldn't yeah yeah he'd
probably run it
he'd be straight producing
he'd be the guy in the dark man
and cut
[Laughter]
if there were a half-assed american
squid game uh which is inevitable uh
what would be the kids games in it what
would be the deadlift deadly american
kids games well four square for sure i i
use like they play ultimate stakes
foursquare to me that that was the my
version of the elementary school like
that was what we played at my school
that envelope flipping game at the
beginning would just be pogs which is
like old old 90s kids would be like hey
i want to play some punks i think it's
tetherball and if it hits you in the
face it explodes yeah i would be dead
immediately it did make tetherball was
like not cool
it did make me feel old that none of
them knew how to play marbles because i
remember kids playing marbles when i was
a kid like i didn't realize that was
that old
did you fall into a time tunnel i mean
my god like no i mean it wasn't like
everybody was walking around with like a
sack of marbles oh my god but i knew how
to play marbles i just realized it would
probably all be licensed stuff it'd be
like monopoly and like
sorry
yeah it's just some old guy like oh just
like my youth i remember this trigger
shooting i mean
laser tag i feel like the american
version of this would have a laser tag
left yeah except the lasers like burn
you that is real okay i'm gonna take us
off track for two seconds i promise i'll
be right back but after i was recovering
from my accident i my uh boyfriend at
the time was like oh my friend is having
a laser attack thing you should come and
he was like you should play it i'm like
i absolutely can't play laser tag right
now and so i'm like trying to play and
trying to slink and i'm realizing that
there's a girl behind me who was using
me as
freaking cover
but i didn't realize that until i like
tripped over her as i'm moving backwards
and she's like
sorry bruh and i'm like i just got hit
by a boss
and that person was ender from ender's
game
[Laughter]
how you get ahead in the squid games
yeah
listen the winter time yeah this ties
into a question from brent dreyer so uh
uh speaking of ender's game and squid
games we're all agreed that this and the
purge takes place in the same universe
yeah i think this could just be the
korean purge but it's too elite and like
often its own
kind of thing i think you need to like
buy a pay-per-view to watch this the
purge seems like everybody gets a chance
which is nice yeah which i do also think
that you buy on pay-per-view but i think
it's just like mostly like weird
stoplight cameras and stuff um this is
definitely one where you i think you do
have to fly in like they fly you in you
fly in on like fancy air you drink your
champagne those masks are at least a
million each like they're not wearing
cheap guy masks like they're wearing
like very it's gonna be heavy too it's
like burning man yeah you're working
here it's very telling that the foreign
show is like
these rich people paying to watch the
poor is like compete and yeah the
american version like the purge is like
it's the government man it's government
overreach what can you do about this
government that's why we shouldn't have
a government it's like our our version
is not you know not quite as forthright
about interesting well there's there's
more going on in the purge if you if you
dive deep still like that's not
a class critique of comments i'm just
kidding it's also a class critique i
understand uh yeah i'm just a bit i'm a
purge head too um and now we'll edit
this juan burgos says uh what do you
think will happen in the second season
are we gonna go back i mean we're gonna
have another squid game right i think
there's no way to do squid game two
without another split game yeah um or
are they gonna go like skip to the later
hunger games in the later battle rail
where it's like it's like more of a war
or a revolution or are we going back in
that game
i think we have to go back into the game
for at least half of the series before
you get to the revolution part yeah you
need all the all-star round which i
believe is the hunger games too they
they they fell back yeah that will start
i'd still watch squid games all-stars
for sure i i definitely feel like you
need another season and maybe like
instead of the cop next season we'll be
following the you know like be hung from
this season and his investigation
while we cut back to the new squid gate
because obviously this season ends with
like the squid game remains active and
is still in progress like when he sees
the
the salesman you know playing the square
game with a new
victim or target or whatever yeah so
yeah we've already established the squid
game is just going to keep happening and
i feel like season two will definitely
be new squid game new players maybe new
vips
maybe better graphics
downloadable content it's basically fifa
squid game is
right who will be on the cover of next
year's twitter
oh they should make this a yearly series
anyways we have so many ideas uh they
can't even be contained by this video
but please come back come back next week
uh where we will be discussing another
one that has been
well if this one was too fast this next
one is too slow uh probably because it's
been uh delayed so many times i know
that doesn't really narrow it down but
that's just the way that's just the way
movies go these days um but next week
you finally get your chance to go back
and i hope you enjoy it very much uh
just like i hope you enjoyed this week's
episode thank you danielle thank you lon
we'll see you all tomorrow bye
[Music]
you